Oh Lord affair caught on text and
charges of extortion that's the state of
play between one of the wealthiest men
on the planet and the most famous
tabloid in American history trace
Gallagher has the story tonight from our
West Coast newsroom that's buzzing trace
hi Laura yeah when the world's richest
man says he was blackmailed by the
world's most famous tabloid it tends to
generate a little buzz and now you have
the feds involved first Bezos went on a
blogging platform called medium and
posted details of the alleged extortion
including messages sent to him from the
National Enquirer its parent company
American media and American media CEO
David pecker threatening to release
intimate photos of Bezos and his
girlfriend Lauren Sanchez
unless Bezos agreed to one call off his
investigation of how the Enquirer got
the private pictures and text and to
issued a statement saying the
investigation that uncovered his affair
with Sanchez was not politically
motivated well vases of course refused
writing quote of course I don't want
personal photos published but I also
won't participate in their well-known
practice of blackmail political favors
political attacks and corruption I
prefer to stand up roll this log over
and see what crawls out American media
has now responded saying it wasn't
blackmailing Bezos and that the messages
were good faith negotiations to resolve
the matter saying quote American media
believes fervently that it acted
lawfully in the reporting of the story
of mr. Bezos now that said American
media CEO David pecker says the company
will conduct its own investigation into
what if any action needs to be taken and
the government is also getting in on the
action federal prosecutors are now
looking into the national Enquirer's
handling of the Bezos extramarital
affair story as for how the intimate
photos were leaked in the first place a
reporter for The Washington Post owned
by Jeff Bezos says that he has spoken
with Bezos lead security consultant
Gavin de Becker watch Gavin de Becker
told us that he does not believe that
Jeff Bezos his phone was hacked
he thinks it's possible
that a government entity might have
gotten hold of his text messages though
earlier Gavin de Becker said publicly he
thought the brother of Bezos mistress
Lauren Sanchez played a role in leaking
those private photos in texts we shall
see Laura tres great job and our next
guest finds the invasion of privacy
complaint from Bezos warranted but also
hypocritical filmmaker Peter Schweitzer
has a new documentary that examines how
these tech behemoths operate in stolen
and manipulated information that's your
information by the way Peter joins us
now Peter that National Enquirer seems
to be in the wrong here with how they
came after Beezus but it's kind of
ironic isn't it that Bezos is crying
foul about stolen text when these tech
companies can be guilty in the end of
much worse yeah that's exactly right
Laura you know about a decade ago Eric
Schmidt of Google declared that privacy
was dead and the tech Titans have have
essentially been selling everybody's
information and what's troubling is they
don't just use that information our
information to you know sell us
advertising and sort of things like that
they also use it against us and so to me
it's quite ironic I sympathize with Jeff
Bezos but I find it quite ironic that
they're raising privacy concerns when
the high tech industry primarily Google
and Facebook but also Amazon peddle in
selling our information and invading our
privacy on a regular basis
well Peter another point is that the
employees the Washington Post to
ultimately work for Beezus saw that one
blog post basically try out the National
Enquirer and are just celebrating him as
a national hero let's watch there is a
certain amount of badassness about Jeff
Bezos that I think makes us all proud
too proud of work form badassness that's
that's where we are I want to play one
more thing though because this is funny
this is Dylan Byers of NBC also saying
that this all could be
good in a way for Beezus let's watch to
me it's not so much what does National
Enquirer have on Jeff Bezos that's
driving this story what I wonder is what
does Jeff Bezos maybe have on the
National Enquirer what does he have
about the ties to Trump he's earned his
journalism wings with this move so he
has he has pulled off a masterstroke in
terms of recasting his own image in
terms of making himself look like a good
guy again that's a pretty interesting
turn a good guy a hero she's a guy just
like you and me Donny Deutsch said on
morning at Morning Joe so it is kind of
an imagery cast
but then again picker has already he's
already gotten an immunity deal from
Muller so it's like he's working with
Muller on some of this kills killing the
stories about Trump deal so I don't get
where any of these people are going that
what do you have to hide what is am i
have to hide I don't get it yeah now
look it's interesting Jeff Bezos is in
this story kind of the victim right so
that's going to help him but I think
most people are going to look at these
tech Titans ultimately not view them in
a sympathetic light and it's not I'm in
my book because they make a lot of money
more power to them they create these
great companies these great products and
services but it's because of the
invasion of privacy with all these
online companies including Amazon a big
part of their revenue stream is selling
information about you and they use that
information against you some of them at
Google and others talk about the fact
that their goal is not just to sell you
information it's to actually change and
manipulate your values and your views so
look I sympathize with Jeff Bezos in
this case but to paint him as some kind
of a victim like the rest of us I think
is patently ridiculous Peter before we
go I got to get your quick quick
thoughts on Hillary Clinton who I guess
is you know maybe they just need a woman
to get the job done over there running
for president I mean she's still she's
still dangling out the prospect of
running and it looked a little more
likely today that she was actually gonna
throw her hat in the ring with
everything that you exposed about
Hillary the email server how good would
that be
well I think it would be an enormous
gift to President Trump if Hillary
Clinton were to run what I'm betting on
is that Terry McAuliffe the former
governor of Virginia will be the
stalking horse for the Clinton machine
their longtime associates he raised a
lot of money for them when Bill was
president they helped him get elected
governor of Virginia so they're gonna
try to live vicariously through Terry
McAuliffe and go up against the Obama
machine in 2020 with their candidate now
I think it's gonna be quite a slugfest
Wow
Peter thanks so much we really
appreciate it tonight